what the heck is manifesting Mel Robbins
well let me tell you what manifesting
isn't okay manifesting is not thinking
thoughts and then hoping that they come
true thoughts become things only when
your thoughts inspire you to take the
actions to get those things that's where
manifesting comes in manifesting is
preparing your mind body and spirit to
help you take the actions to get those
things that's right I'm going to say
that again manifesting is like training
forgetting what you want hey it's Evan
Carmichael and this channel is created
to help you overcome the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you've got
Michael Jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how to manifest success
into your life enjoy
manifesting is socializing your mind
preparing your mind rehearsing your mind
to help you take the steps before you
take the steps so that you can get what
you want when you use manifesting
properly what you do is you remove the
obstacles of self-doubt of resistance of
being cautious of focusing on Tiny
minutia of feeling blank and overwhelmed
you remove all that crap and you retrain
your mind and you retrain your nervous
system and you retrain your spirit to
help you get the things that you want in
life and when you manifest properly what
it does is it inspires you to take the
actions that lead you to what you want
now that sounds like a lot alike okay
Mel what does that actually mean what it
means is this manifesting is going to
help you see feel and act your way
toward the things that you want that's
what it does it's so freaking cool now
let me tell you the difference between
manifesting according to science and
wishing wanting hoping dreaming let's
focus on sort of wishing
there's a lot of you that are confusing
wishing for something with manifesting
okay they're the opposite ends of the
spectrum and so before I kind of explain
the two let me just give you an example
so that we can use the example to
compare and to contrast okay one big
goal and dream that a lot of people have
is Financial Freedom the ability to take
your kids to Disney World the ability to
buy what you want the ability to put
enough money away so that you don't have
to worry about money the ability to buy
the things that you need to go on the
trips that you want Financial Freedom is
something that you deserve in your life
it's something that you can do the work
to achieve in your life and so let's
talk about the goal of Financial Freedom
and the difference between wishing for
Financial Freedom and hoping and
dreaming about it versus manifesting and
doing the work to go get it and what's
the difference between you wanting and
wishing for Financial Freedom
and you manifesting it and using
manifestation and the science of it to
help you get it the big difference
between wishing for something and using
manifesting to help you do the work to
go get it is that when you wish that you
were financially free have you ever
noticed that the second that you wish
for something like you know I wish I
would win the lottery you're also
present at the same time to the fact
that you're lacking money right now like
wishing that you would win the lottery
it doesn't bring up all of this sort of
like empowering feelings what what it
does is it reminds you that you're so
broke that you need to win the lottery
and that's very different than
manifesting manifesting is declaring
what you want I am committed to creating
Finance freedom in my life
and then once you declare what you want
manifesting is about the actions and
empowering yourself to go get it
and there's a really big difference
between focusing on you know and wishing
for something which only reminds you
that you're lacking it you know oh I I
wish I would meet somebody that just
makes you feel more alone I wish I could
get in shape that just makes you feel
more out of shape I wish I could win the
lottery that just makes you feel poorer
I wish I didn't have to work for this
jerk that just makes you feel more stuck
do you feel how wishing for something
amplifies what you don't like versus
I'm gonna manifest and work for more
money in my life I am committed to being
in a loving relationship and I'm going
to manifest and make it happen I uh
deserve to have a career that I love and
I'm going to use manifesting to help me
get it
I want to be in incredible shape I want
to do a handstand in yoga I want to heal
my trauma and I'm going to use
manifesting to help me achieve those
things that's a big difference wishing
and hoping makes you present to what you
don't have
manifesting makes you present and
feeling empowered about what you want
and your ability to go get it and that
highlights the second big difference
when you hope for things when you wish
for things you are handing the power
to somebody else or to outside forces
you are literally giving away your power
because hoping and wishing
just inherently assumes that somebody
else is somehow going to come in and
solve the problem we all know that
that's not happening manifesting on the
other hand locates and amplifies the
power inside of you to do the work to
get those things to do the work to
change your life and it's important that
you locate the power inside of you
because you're the one that's
responsible for your dreams and you're
also the person that's in the best
position to make those dreams a reality
because you have the ability to change
the way that you think you have the
ability to change the actions that you
take every single day and when you
change the actions that you take and you
change the way that you think you change
your entire life and manifesting is a
tool
that will help you train your brain and
train your nervous system and train your
mind body and spirit to help you achieve
the things that you want the the thing
that's super important for you to get is
a major takeaway from this video is the
thoughts alone
won't achieve the things that you desire
but if you manifest properly
it will inspire you to take action an
action is what will create the results
that you deserve and that you want in
your life that's as simply as I can put
it rule number two is visualize with
Brendan burchard how many of you in this
room actually know
already
how to improve your life you already
know where to focus on your life and you
probably know what to do but you haven't
done it yet be honest raise your hands
okay about half the room of Truth
tellers
and half the room I'll just pretend you
didn't hear the questions
because who knows exactly what you need
to do to change already right people say
ah I want to lose weight Brendan
I don't know why I haven't lost weight
I'll say do you know how
yes
have you gone to the gym
so people know what to do it's that they
failed to do it
that essence
is called Common Sense we know what to
do but the failure in the practice
comes from a failure sometimes of will
sometimes of circumstance sometimes of
something but here's what I love you to
do if you're failing to implement
something you know you should already do
please tune in
if you are failing to implement
something you already know you can do
your vision
for your life
is stuck to today
your vision is stuck to yesterday
because if you have a different vision
for your life and you know what to do
and that vision is compelling that
vision is something that is real and
important and exciting for you guess
what you do it
if it's a fake vision
a mimic revision a Follow the Leader
Vision not your vision that's why you're
not doing the basics right if you
haven't lost the weight you don't have a
vision for your life healthfully yet
you want to lose pounds but you have an
envisioned a healthy life
so even the common sensical things you
don't do it right who is eating a
freaking bag of chips in the last 30
days a whole bag of chips who ate that
Mega chips at one sitting foreign
who ate the bag of chips in one sitting
and had to fight not to open the second
bag
so making sure you're all being real
here
but let's go it's not just Health think
about that dream you have you know
you wanted to write like my dream was to
be a writer and a coach right I want to
be a writer and I want to be a life
coach or business coach okay cool that's
what I wanted to do
common sense says Brendan sit down and
write every day but I didn't see it yet
I didn't visualize that vision and own
that dream yet it was an idea but it
wasn't a vision in my heart I didn't see
it feel it walk through it I remember I
said one day I'm going to be comfortable
talking to people
because this is not how I came out of
the womb
I I know for a very long time I was
talking to people and speaking on a
stage especially when that big no thank
you ma'am not of an interest and then I
said well you know what if I really want
to make a difference in the world I have
to communicate better
I really have to get better at that
and so I would lay in bed
every morning
and I would lay there and I would
visualize myself
see a vision of my future on a stage
and I would see myself walk into one
side and saying something amazing and
they would stand on their feet because I
said something amazing and then I went
to the other side and I said something
equally amazing and all the amazing just
kept coming out and people would stand
and they would shout and they would
scream and I would see it and as I was
visualizing that vision of myself guess
what
I would be sitting in bed in complete
anxiety I'd be sweating out the armpits
you ever dream of your vision of your
future and it makes you sweat hey oh I'm
weird okay
are you all here say I'm here
you've never seen a vision of your
future and it kind of freaked you out
if you haven't you're not dreaming big
enough yet babe
if something in the future doesn't scare
the [ __ ] out of you forgive my language
you haven't even started Bremen
if something in the future doesn't scare
you like oh that
like see if I want to be a public
speaker and I don't think of a stage
that big and I don't sweat I better
think of a bigger stage until I start
sweating
right to allow that discomfort that
Vision that's bigger because that's
sometimes uh look we'll talk about
willpower we'll talk about confidence
we'll talk about discipline but I'm here
to tell you a lot of the reason people
don't take daily real practical Common
Sense efforts towards their dreams is
they don't see the dream yet
they haven't laid awake and thought
about it long enough they thought
wouldn't that be nice there's a
difference between wouldn't that be nice
and I own this dream it is in my heart
it is in my legs it is in my body I feel
I sense it that's mine let's go
Jew don't luck into that
you decide what you want and you see it
and you visualize it and you step into
it mentally day after day after day and
people say oh well Brendan what if it
doesn't come true I'm like oh babe it's
highly likely it won't
but
who taught you it was about the
destination
didn't we all learn it's about the
Journey turn the person shake and say
it's about the journey
common practice isn't common practice is
because it is so common
it's mundane efforts every day
common practice it's just same thing it
doesn't look like a lot doesn't feel
like a lot it's a little inches steps
forward incremental advancement it's not
sexy
we want the destination and in the day
when we don't feel the destination we're
like Ugh you know I dream of the big
stage but then my first stage is that
little room you all saw and some people
would go ah well that's not it and I
said oh of course gonna start small keep
trying keep getting better learn to talk
to people get out of my weird shell like
you know not be so awkward and just try
to you know get many words out in a row
it wasn't like oh one day I'm gonna
speak in front of you know this and that
and Arenas that happened and I could see
it and I forced myself to see it but I
would take the common everyday practices
because the Visions were mine they were
my dreams don't think one day you'll
have a vision and become so strong
see a little bit of the vision and keep
visualizing it keep visualizing it keep
seeing it keep visualizing every morning
for like three years I would lay there
and imagine myself talking better
imagine myself on stage working the
stage getting away from the podium
right you don't see a Podium there's
nothing up here there's not a chair up
here at all I got 38 feet to work here
and then I got another mile
to lap the room
I'm gonna work it I'm oh I had to see
myself walking that's weird okay yeah
walk Brandon move get you know get you
have to see this stuff you all with me
so far
[Music]
don't think the vision has to be
complete
the vision has to be tapped every day
tap into it see it think about it see it
think about it see it think about it and
it comes into more formation everyone
wants their Vision their dream delivered
as a complete Netflix package I'm like
that's not how it goes you see a little
piece of it and you
observe it and play it out see another
piece observe it think it out observe it
think it out observe it think it out
rule number three organize your mind
with sad Guru everything we as human
beings have created
on this planet
but essentially fast created in our
minds
all that you see which is
human work on this planet
first
found expression in the mind then it got
manifested
in the outside world
the wonderful things that we have done
on this planet
and the horrible things that we have
done on this planet both have come from
the human mind so if we are concerned as
to what we create in this world
it's extremely important that first of
all we learn to create the right things
in our mind how we keep our minds
if we do not have the power to keep our
minds the way we want it
what we create in the world is also
going to be very accidental and
haphazard
so learning to create our minds the way
we want is the basis of creating the
world the way we want
there is a wonderful story in the yogic
law
on a certain day a man took a walk he
went for a long walk
accidentally unawares he walked into
Paradise fortunate isn't he
he just took a walk and he landed up in
Paradise
after this long walk he felt
a little tired
so he thought oh I'm tired I wish I
could rest somewhere
he looked around there there was a nice
tree
underneath which there was very cushiony
grass
so it was inviting he went and put his
head down there and slept
after a few hours he woke up
well rested and he thought oh I am well
rested
but I'm feeling hungry I wish I had
something to eat
he thought about all the nice things
that he ever wanted to eat in his life
and instantly all those things appeared
in front of him
you need to understand they have the
services like that
people don't ask questions
food came and he ate
stomach became full
then he thought
oh my stomach is full I wish I had
something to drink
all the nice things that he ever wanted
to drink
he thought about it and all of them just
appeared in front of him drinking people
also don't ask questions so he drank
now with a little bit of alcohol in him
you know Charles Darwin told you all of
you are monkeys your tail fell away not
me Charles Darwin told you that you were
all monkeys and your tail fell away and
then you became human yes definitely the
tail fell away but the monkey
in yoga we always refer to an
unestablished mind
as merkata which means a monkey
why we are referring to the Mind as a
monkey is
what are the qualities of a monkey
one thing about a monkey is it's a
necessary moment
and another thing about the monkey is
if I say you're monkeying somebody what
does it mean imitation
monkey and imitation have become
synonymous
so these two essential qualities of a
monkey are very much the qualities of an
unestablished mind unnecessary moment
you don't have to learn it from the
monkey you can teach it to the monkey
and imitation is full-time job of the
Mind
so when these two qualities are on a
mind is referred to as a monkey
so this monkey became active within him
he just looked around thought what the
hell is happening here
I asked for food food came
I asked for drink drink came
there must be ghosts around here
and ghosts came
oh the ghosts have come they're going to
surround me and torture me he thought
immediately the ghosts surrounded him
and started torturing him
then he started screaming in pain and
said oh they're going to kill me and he
died
just now he said he's a fortunate being
the problem is he was sitting under a
kalpa rickshaw or a wishing tree
he asked for food food came he asked for
drink drink came he asked for ghosts
ghost came he asked for torture torture
came he asked for death death happened
now don't go looking for these kalpa
rukshas in the forest you can barely
find a tree
these days
a well-established mind
a mind which is in a state of samyukti
is referred to as a kalpa vixen
if you organize your mind to a certain
level of organization it in turn
organizes the whole system your body
your emotion your energies everything
it's organized in the direction once all
these four dimensions of you your
physical body
your mind your emotion and the
fundamental life energies are organized
in One Direction once you are like this
anything that you wish happens without
even lifting a little finger actually
to assist it with activity but
even without doing any activity you can
still manifest what you want if you
organize these four dimensions
in One Direction and keep it unwavering
in that direction for a certain period
of time
right now the problem with your mind is
every moment it is changing its
direction
it is like you want to travel somewhere
and every two steps if you keep changing
your direction the question of you
reaching the destination is very remote
unless it happens by chance
so organizing our minds and in turn
organizing the whole system and these
four basic dimensions of who you are
right now in One Direction if you do
this you are a kalpa raksha yourself
anything that you wish will happen
but right now if you look at your lives
everything that you have wished for till
now if it happens you're finished
everything and everybody that you have
desired for if all of that lands up in
your house today could you live with
that
once we're empowered like this it's very
important that our physical action
emotional action mental action and
energy actions are controlled and
properly directed
if it is not so we become destructive
self-destructive right now that is our
problem the technology which is supposed
to make our life beautiful and easy has
become the source of all the problem
that we are destroying the very basis of
our life which is the planet
so what should have been a boon we are
making a curse out of it
what has brought incredible levels of
comfort and convenience to us in the
last
100 years or so has also become a threat
to our life simply because we are not
conscious action we are in a compulsive
state of action
so organizing our minds fundamentally
means moving from a compulsive state of
activity to a conscious state of
activity also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four create from the quantum
field with Dr Joe dispenza when we
create from three-dimensional reality
we're creating from lack and separation
in other words you're driving down the
road and see someone driving a car that
all of a sudden you realize that you
don't have the moment you become aware
that that person has that car and you
don't have it you're in lack of having
it right so what the brain naturally
does is it naturally creates you driving
that car and you have an image of
yourself driving in that car and you
start identifying wow that would be a
greater experience for me to have
the problem is the distance between the
thought of what you want
and the experience of actually happening
it happening for most people is the
concept called time right between cause
and effect right so some people develop
the ability to manage themselves and
manage their life develop certain skills
and they can pay for it and they can get
it very quickly the problem is when the
novelty of that experience wears off you
know the car and they're no longer
identifying with that and the feeling of
emptiness and lack comes back they need
to find something else to find something
else and so there's this game that goes
on where you never have enough right and
that's the lack game right
so then if you think about people uh
having the things they want in their
life when they create from lack and
separation it's the experience in
three-dimensional reality that produces
the emotion and the emotion is saying
let's feel that experience this thing
that you've been in lack and separation
from and that emotion then takes away
the lack of Separation but you've worked
really hard to get it okay nothing wrong
with that
is there another way to do it yes okay
so
the person who's living in lack is
waiting for their wealth to feel
abundant
they're waiting for their success to
feel empowered they're waiting for their
healing to feel gratitude they're
waiting for their new relationship to
feel love they're waiting for the
mystical experience to feel awe that's
the Newtonian model of reality of cause
and effect you know waiting for that
event to happen to take away this
separation or lack nothing wrong with it
it's the way most people create but what
we've discovered is actually something
else
the moment
you feel gratitude your Healing Begins
the moment you feel worthy and abundant
you're generating wealth
the moment you're empowered you are
moving towards your success the moment
you're in love with yourself and you're
in love with life
you'll create an equal the moment you
are in awe of life you're going to have
a mystical experience and so that's
causing an effect right
so then if you can teach people then
how to create instead of from lack or
separation but create from wholeness
and create from what we call the quantum
field
instead of three-dimensional reality
what's the difference Okay so
the way you first of all it takes
knowledge okay the quantum field is an
invisible field of energy that exists
beyond our senses you can't see it you
can't smell it you can't taste it you
can't hear it you can't feel it it
exists beyond our experience of
three-dimensional reality would this be
in the our minds Consciousness or would
this be in a different space okay let's
let's look at that so the answer to the
question is how much of your waking day
do you put your attention on matter on
the material world
and how much of your awaken gay are you
aware of energy and frequency for most
people they're unaware of the quantum
field and if you're unaware of it
it doesn't exist for you just like you
have a nose but if you're unaware of it
it doesn't exist for you the moment you
become aware of it exists well the
quantum field you can ask you could
study all kinds of Science and they'll
tell you there is this invisible field
of frequency and energy that exists
beyond the senses that tend to connect
everything physical and material in fact
everything physical and material is
connected to this field Okay so
how do you get there right how do you
get how do you get there how do you get
there so we discovered that when you
take all of your attention off your body
and you are not paying attention to your
emotions your drives your habits
if you take all of your attention off of
every element in your environment your
cell phone your tablet your computer uh
your your car your whatever it is your
bad to take your attention away from
everything every place that you live
where you sleep or you work and you're
not thinking about time you're not
thinking about your schedule where you
need to be or what happened yesterday
you can relax into the present moment
there there tends to be a dramatic
change in the way the brain functions
when people do this properly we call it
getting Beyond yourself but in a sense
you're dissociating from your
three-dimensional reality why because if
you're thinking about anything in your
three-dimensional reality that's where
your attention is and that's where your
energy is okay so
we kind of figured out this formula when
people really become nobody no one no
thing nowhere and no time we are pretty
much all of a sudden outside the
constraints of the Newtonian world of
got to do something to get an outcome
and if you can teach people how to
linger there without a name without a
face without a profession
without a family without a culture
without a past without a disease you
teach them how to be in this place we
call the unknown right
and you teach them that from that place
that invisible field is where everything
material comes from and if they could
create coherence in their brain they
need a strong signal in the brain the
more coherent the brain the more
stronger the signal what do you mean a
strong signal
okay let's see how I could say this
when most people we look at when we look
at brains in real time and we're looking
at people's how their how their mind is
working
when you're under stress okay stress is
created by not being able to predict
something that's going to happen in your
life uh the perception that something's
going to get worse or you can't control
something right so when that occurs we
switch on that perimeter nervous system
called the fight-or-flight nervous
system and the Brain goes into this very
alarmed State called high beta that
means pay attention to the outer world
there's danger out there so it's
but if it's not a predator in its
traffic or your co-worker or your ex
this is where it gets to be a problem
because it becomes very maladaptive
right so when we're in that state and
the brain is that in that around State
we try to control and predict everything
so every person every object everything
every place uh every even your body has
a neurological Network in your brain
right so as the arousal happens we start
shifting our attention to all these
elements and like a lightning storm in
the clouds the brain starts firing very
very incoherently and when the brain's
incoherent we're in coherence so that's
not a strong signal that's not there's
it's a static on The Wire that's
disconnection there is no signal right
so
when we're in that state we're always
really looking for the worst case
scenario of what's going to happen
because if you prepare for the worst
anything less that happens a better
chance of survival right so so in this
kind of aroused State as we shift our
attention to each one of these elements
that are known in our environment the
brain starts compartmentalizing and
firing out of order and and
that is what creates what's called
autonomic dysregulation that causes the
brain and body to get really out of
balance right so in that state we're
we're over focused you know when you're
stressed you're over focused on
something you can't stop thinking about
it
our research
shows that when you do that you actually
make your brain worse because you're
analyzing your problems within some
disturbing emotion and that emotion is
driving you further out of bounds you're
actually knocking your brain and body
out of balance by thought alone and
you're driving it into these more
aroused States right for someone that's
been living like that for decades that's
their Base today how do they even
realize how to get out of that they
don't usually it takes crisis right it
takes trauma extreme breakdown breakdown
it's a loss of yeah a breakup a divorce
a near bankruptcy whatever it is a
disease a diagnosis whatever something
where you just can't go on business as
usual now it's time to really start
looking they have to wake out there yeah
so so let's get back to the concept of
abundance here because I need a strong
signal in this field right so then
if you can teach people to do the exact
opposite go from putting all of their
attention on everything physical and
material in the world of separation and
instead of narrowing their focus on
something material ask them to broaden
their focus and put it on nothing
now I know that sounds kind of crazy but
when you put your attention on space and
you divert your attention the act of
sensing without thinking actually starts
to slow the brain waves down not only
slow it down
but all of a sudden cause the brain to
start re reintegrating starts to
synchronize right and so you see
different compartments of the brain that
were firing out of order start to
resonate they start to communicate
they're they're they're they're they're
all of a sudden synchronizing and what
sinks in the brain kind of links in the
brain so when a person has their whole
entire brain firing in Rhythm that's a
very strong signal that you can send out
into the field if that signal is strong
in that position what can you create
from that spot okay so but that's only
one element okay
so then the clear intention tends to be
a very important element that we have to
have to get down and the more coherent
the brain
the more clear the signal for that
intention so with intention and
attention we could actually make thought
more real than anything else now what is
that you're saying what would it be like
to be wealthy what would it be like to
be abundant what would it like to have
all my needs met what would it be like
to have more than I need what would I do
if I had everything I ever wanted the
answer always is the same you start
giving stuff away because if an abundant
person is truly abundant why would they
hold on they would say there's I'm not
in lack there's more for everybody okay
turns out though that the signal sent
out isn't enough you got to have to draw
the experience back to you so setting
the signal out to you know Financial
Freedom or whatever that is all these
different things right right whatever
that is for you whatever that is putting
that out there with the signal that with
the intention and the attention right
and then how do you drive physical world
right in the physical world you got to
go get it you got to do something this
is the plan of demonstration you got to
go get it and when you you're in lack
until it occurs right
so what I'm hearing you say there's a
way to not Chase but attract all right
so if you're creating from the field
instead of from matter right
there's a very strong possibility that
you'll shorten the distance between the
thought of what you want and the
experience of having it and when there's
a vibrational match between your energy
and that future that you want to
experience now if you're creating from
the field you actually don't go anywhere
to get it you actually draw it to you
rule number five have the right Thoughts
with Dean graziosi I have a message that
I'm going to tell through a story
with my daughter so last weekend and yes
this has to do with success has to do
with happiness when I say success I want
you to have a full rounded uh definition
of success money without happiness money
without health health without money all
of it's a pain in the ass unless you
have all of it so why not work on the
core
work on the foundation like I always say
all success starts here because all
success starts with your habits and your
values before the Magic Money machines
before the businesses before the grit
before the grind you need the habits so
let me tell you this story uh one of the
greatest things ever taught I believe is
what Earl Nightingale uh so simply put
in The Strangest Secret that we are
nothing more than the sum total of our
thoughts now we know that we hear it
you've heard me share it you've read
about it but how does it actually stick
in your life how does it work in your
life are you aware that you are nothing
more than the total of your thoughts you
will become the person that
follows or obeys the thoughts that you
have if you have thoughts of scarcity of
thoughts of of getting taken advantage
of get thoughts of being the victim get
thoughts of have thoughts of being an
entrepreneur who can handle anything an
entrepreneur who could just go to the
the ends of the Earth and do what it
takes I mean everything is everything
starts with a thought but let me just
share this with you
my daughter and my son and I went to
Utah last weekend fishing uh well just
fishing was one of the things we did we
just wanted to hang out get out of the
Heat and still hot here in Arizona so we
want to get out so we jump on a plane
and we go to uh Park City Utah having an
amazing time we go fishing we learn how
to fly I hire some coaches to help my
kids to get better uh dear friends
actually helping
um we did Outdoor Sports we went bowling
we did all this great stuff long story
short my daughter's 11. and whether
you're a parent or not I'm just telling
you I had no idea that girl drama starts
at about 10. it's like the plane lifts
off the ground at 10 and girl drama
starts girls are getting in clicks girls
are making fun of other girls it's and
and I'm not saying the girls like boys
are bad but boys are kind of wanting off
to play sports at this age and and
fortnite uh anyway the drama starts so
my daughter is very um like I was she
she needs everybody to like her to feel
good about herself now I work on that
all the time telling her you know she
needs her own self-worth but she's 11
and we're working on it so long
long short we're coming back on this
Sunday and
she wants to come back to go to a yoga
class with three of her friends that
she's kind of on the edge with they're
kind of clicky great girls amazing girls
but that's just the way it is doesn't
make any kids better my daughter's not
any better than any of those other girls
but she wanted to really go and it was
important to her she said Dad I really
want to go to the yoga class and then
lunch after and I can bond with these
girls it'll just make it so much easier
in school because I really like them and
one of them she felt bad for because
she's moving and she really likes her
all this stuff so I cut the trip short I
said okay Brie you want to go back for
that I understand I was your age once
now we changed the flight to get there
with an hours uh cushion yeah I cut
things kind of close but we had an hour
hour and a half cushion we get to the
airport the flight's delayed for an hour
uh we didn't fly private we flied
commercial we just had fun we went up
there but we were an hour late so now
we're an hour late and did you ever fly
into planes they're not super small not
super big but they they can't handle the
the big roll-on bags so you got to leave
them in the jet way and then they have
to unpa you know you basically have to
check the bag so we had to check the bag
and all of a sudden I'm looking at time
and we're going to land at about the
exact time this yoga class starts and it
was so important to my daughter I get it
you might say I was a dumb yog class no
it was more of that 11 year old girl
trying to you know do the right thing it
was a big deal to her so all of a sudden
now why am I telling you this whole
story because I watched my daughter say
Dad we're not going to make it Dad we're
going to be late and I watch the stress
and I watched the feeling in her belly
when she was telling herself we weren't
gonna make it
we had not yet gotten there late we had
not yet missed the appointment but the
story her thoughts were already there
the story she was telling herself is
that we were missing it and I watched
her mannerisms change I watched her
physiology change I watched her mood
change she was sad she was thinking of
all these things and I'll miss the class
and then Monday at school be
uncomfortable again because I didn't fix
it with the one friend all of those
thoughts one thing a delay in the flight
triggered 15 other thoughts she wasn't
even my regular daughter that she was
sitting there sad so we're going and I
said here's what I told her I said Bree
now kids don't want lessons all the time
as adults we want them because we want
to go faster but I said Bree
wouldn't it be better to think that
we're gonna make it no matter what we're
going to make it there on time because
whether we make it there on time I'd
rather have the better thought on the
way than being sad so in my head all I
kept saying is however we're going to do
it we're going to make the play the
flight's going to go a little quicker
we're going to get the bags quicker than
we thought I'll drive quicker we'll get
there we'll get and I was fine and I do
this all the time but I've had 50 years
of being on this Earth to figure it out
she's 11.
so long story short we get there on time
we got there 10 minutes early drop her
off she's got a big smile on her face
but she was stressed for two hours the
poor thing so I waited till the next day
and I said Bree really simple
we could have been late
but we weren't but either we were late
or not wouldn't it have been better for
your heart for your health for your
happiness for your the end of a great
trip in Utah with your dad and your
brother wouldn't have been great to say
you know what we're going to make it I'm
gonna be there in time no big deal I'm
gonna get there and I'm gonna bond with
my friends it's going to be amazing and
Monday and school will be great I said
what is that what happened she goes yeah
that's exactly what happened Monday went
you know she ended up telling me
afterwards that Monday went great
because they bonded I said wouldn't it
have been better tell yourself that
story over and over and you would have
had a great plane ride you wouldn't have
had stress you wouldn't have had worry
and she's like wow dad that's the first
time it ever I really understand what
you say about being the witness of your
thoughts or looking at your thoughts or
judge your thoughts so let me ask you
what thoughts could you change right now
listen I'll be completely transparent my
ex-wife who I'm dear friends with and
and
um yeah divorce sucks for lack of a
better word but we've done an amazing
job at it and the reason I'm bringing
that up is because because I watch her
sometimes go down the path of having
thoughts that'll drive her nuts like Why
didn't it work out in the past why
couldn't have we done done something
different or how come this is happening
now and I always tell her I'm like and I
can watch her come right back she'll
she'll get in a grumpy mood I'll drop
the kids off she's like hey short with
me and I know she's letting thoughts get
to her which we all do and then I remind
her she changes her thoughts she's a
completely different person
I remember listening to Wayne Dyer when
he got diagnosed with leukemia it's not
what he passed away at but when he died
when he got diagnosed with leukemia he
said he remembers telling himself oh my
God I'm sick I have leukemia I'm not
going to make it he felt like he said
wait a minute
I'm gonna I have leukemia either way the
end result's going to be the same either
way so I'm just going to think I'm going
to beat it I'm going to be healthy I'm
going to be the example for leukemia
victim sir or people with that disease
he changed it and all of a sudden he was
the happiest guy you ever saw with
leukemia only because he changed one
thing his thoughts so back to you what
thoughts are you having right now that
don't serve you they don't serve your
bigger future judge them analyze them
they are not you there's two of us in
there remember you have double
conversations all the time you're not
schizo we have two conversations you
know you could be walking in a room
while simultaneously you're saying wow
why did they wear that or or wow this is
a weird color uh uh painting that they
put up on the wall like you know we have
two thoughts always going on our head so
with those two thoughts divide one to
analyze your thoughts and be like why
the hell would you think that why would
you think we're going to be late miss it
my friends aren't gonna like me when you
can think I'm gonna be on time my
friends are gonna love me one makes you
feel happy one makes you feel like
one can say I learned from a bad
relationship and my next one's going to
be amazing or my best relationship I
screwed up I suck and I'm always going
to be miserable one makes you happy one
makes you sad Wayne Dyer could have said
I have leukemia this sucks I'm gonna be
sick I'm gonna die or I have leukemia
I'm gonna beat it and I'm gonna still uh
Inspire the world one makes you sad one
makes you happy one makes you empowered
one takes away your power which one do
you want I'm asking you right now to
think about this what are the stinking
thoughts that you're having in your head
that are holding you back causing you
pain making you suffer and not allowing
you go to the next level analyze your
thoughts this week more than ever before
in your life rule number six is be
aligned with feeling good with Gabby
Bernstein where are we going wrong with
manifesting like one of the biggest
mistakes the myths the things that are
not really the right places well first
of all I think that the reason that
you're feeling that way about this book
is because it's actually not about book
about manifesting it's a book about
feeling good
and the key to manifesting and the key
to being a super attractor is to be
aligned with feeling good and that
doesn't mean that we feel good all the
time but our deepest desire isn't to get
that thing to feel good enough and feel
good it's to feel good so that we can
allow whatever we need and whatever's at
the highest good to come into our life
and that's where I think some of the
wobbliness maybe shows up when it comes
to manifesting is this idea that I can
think it and it will be and that's true
you know you can you can think and think
and think to the point of belief and
then that can actually come into form
but more importantly we need to really
make it our commitment and our devotion
to feel good and that may mean looking
at some of our shadows that may mean
having the willingness to change our
mind all throughout the day and that may
mean being more committed to our
well-being and our personal growth than
we ever had before but in the pursuit of
feeling good having a good life and
being a super attractor yeah amazing so
it actually starts with us and what I'm
hearing you say is just that we know
that it's not about getting that thing
yeah but the challenge is that somehow
in that Pursuit it always becomes about
that even if that thing is something
elusive like a title or a status or you
know being on a list or whatever it may
be like it ends up being that way how
did you you said something really
interesting to me when you walked in you
would and I was congratulating you
because the book's already in New York
Times uh bestseller right the book's
been number one on the list which is
unbelievable oh it's been like three
three five and six three weeks in a row
okay we're number one on Amazon yeah
number one on Amazon right so it's been
so it's got all that but and I said that
to you and I congratulated you and I
showed you a picture that you posted I
was like this is amazing and you said
something really interesting to me yeah
say what you said I very much said that
the reason that it's not it's on these
lists is because I don't give a [ __ ]
like I I stopped caring all I cared
about with this book this is my seventh
book
and all I cared about with this book
because in many of my other books I
really cared about lists and things like
that but with this book and that didn't
mean that there wasn't major service
behind them and the primary intention
being to serve because if that wasn't
the case they wouldn't have had success
but my agenda was different at times and
you know it's more in the the marketing
of it and this time around I was like
I'm gonna show up and do my part but I'm
just gonna have fun I'm gonna feel good
I'm gonna relax and I'm not gonna think
about it you know the day that my
Publishers called me and said the book
is on the list I didn't even realize it
was Wednesday which is the day I could
have cared less I wasn't thinking about
it at all I didn't even recognize the
day it was and that's been happening
every week every Wednesday I keep
getting these text messages oh it's
number five is number six and I'm like
oh yeah it's Wednesday
oh okay cool you know and I'm
celebrating it but I'm celebrating it
mainly from the perspective like like
today these these you know this
acknowledgment of the these lists and
things really just represent that it's
helping people yes exactly which I think
is which I think is such an important
thing to celebrate that's right because
we're celebrating the fact that a book
about being a super attractor
is growing as opposed to a book about
something negative or something there is
that definitely and I also all seeing
like I wrote this book because I
have it made me feel good which it did
multiple cases were even returned to it
on my own to read it I knew that if it
was making me feel good that it was
definitely going to make the reader feel
good and that's that's today I was at
lunch and a woman you know grabbed me
and was like look I just have the
audiobook right now and I'm listening to
you right now and I was like awesome and
she said it's making me feel so good I
said well then I've done my job I love
that that's awesome now you've you've
talked a lot about how
you know we're living at a time when
there's a lot of competition there's a
lot of uh comparing there's a lot of you
know me versus this or competitors and
peers and all that kind of stuff and but
in this book you know and a lot of that
makes us feel like what I'm hearing you
say you're like oh I'm having fun like
I'm enjoying it but a lot of us turn to
being strict with ourselves whereas you
take an approach of saying let's be
compassionate with us tell me about that
almost Paradox because we almost feel
like okay well if I'm competing I need
to get more organized and more strict
and more whereas you're actually saying
no be more compassionate yeah one of the
biggest blocks to being a super
attractor is the comparison and the
belief that there's not enough to go
around and I actually wrote a whole
chapter in the book called there's more
than enough to go around I love that
yeah and it's for that person that's
like The Pusher or that I identified in
the book the person that's like if I
don't do it it won't happen
and everybody around me is better than
me or I'm not or I'm better than
everybody else and that separation and
that judgment that self-attack and all
the ways that we feel unworthy and so
when we start to identify the ways that
we're pushing and controlling we can
begin to unpack that and I guide the
reader in the book to unpack that
behavior and to recognize how much it's
blocking someone from from allowing and
letting what they desire to come into
their life because the real secret is to
feel good the secret is to love where
you are in the moment and not compare
yourself to where you think you should
be because once you start just being
psyched about what is more of what you
desire comes to you and I can stand
behind that wholeheartedly
wholeheartedly and rule number seven the
last one before some very special bonus
Clips is create a new pattern with Lewis
house so we're working to reprogram your
mind and break the patterns that have
been leading your life because I've been
there in so many different areas of my
life for many different years that have
held me back and some I've been
confident in certain areas and others
I've lacked confidence and this is a
process and this is a journey and it's
not going to happen overnight but we
want to identify where your energy is
going
and focus on where is that energy and
effort leading you and helping you and
as the author of The Secret
Rhonda Byrne told me in our interview
last year she said when you start
noticing a damaging pattern you can
replace it with a new one but you need
to identify what the patterns are I
think sometimes we get we just aren't
even aware it's just a pattern that's
running it's something that's happening
maybe it's been happening for months or
years or decades we're not even aware
it's just become our identity so when
you identify
the negative identity patterns that are
holding you back that's the first step
and you can start to really shift and
replace it with a new identity a new
pattern that you can Implement and you
want to think about the people in your
life now are the people you spend your
time with giving you energy or are they
draining you of your energy and this is
also you know a side note just because
someone
maybe doesn't agree with you or has
different beliefs or you know makes you
feel reactive doesn't mean that they're
all they're always this toxic person you
get to figure out how you can respond to
people because not everyone's going to
be a perfect human being around you all
day long you've got to learn how to
respond and let go of the triggers that
have been holding you back it's usually
never about the other person it's always
about why is this hurting me why is this
affecting me yes if someone's being
nasty towards you and and saying mean
things to you and deliberately and
intentionally trying to hurt you that is
not okay but sometimes it's just a
misinterpretation sometimes it's a
miscommunication and we get so triggered
I know because this used to be me we get
so triggered and so angry we hold on to
this that doesn't help you it's
typically never about the other person
it's usually always about the thing we
need to let go of and heal in our past
so that we can be less reactive to
Life's daily interactions so you want to
think about you know who are those
people that maybe maybe the they are
draining you or maybe you need to figure
out how to let go of your reactions and
if you're wanting to manifest loving
relationships around you you want to
start thinking about you know who are
the people that are really supporting me
and those that aren't and are you
keeping people around because you don't
want them to to leave your side or or
you're keeping around because they're
actually adding value and you're
contributing to adding value in their
life as well
and if you were trying to put out in the
world that you do want loving
relationships around you
then then bring the joy that you want to
create and if the people currently
around you don't fall into that desire
then it's time to let them go or just
distance yourself you don't have to say
I'm cutting you out of my life forever
but start to distance yourself to create
time and space for more abundance of
love in your life and for your health
think about your health
you have no idea what you're capable of
you have no idea you have no idea the
person you could be the things you could
accomplish the things you can do the
people you can serve you have no idea
that's why I don't like 10-year goals
10-year goals think about who you used
to be 10 years ago you know could that
person accurately with any with any
degree of certainty predict where you
could be right now now like if you're
growing and you're learning you're
improving and you're expanding
you're invested in yourself there's no
way that you know where you're going to
be in one year let alone five years or
ten years you have no idea what you're
capable of and so it comes down to
questioning everything the question what
you can and can't do you know we're told
the story growing up of what you should
do and we're told everything right
you're told when to show up and where to
go and what to wear and what to eat and
what at what age you should get married
and what kind of crew you should go into
right we're told we should do all these
things you're told you're like who you
know nobody ever thought to ask us what
we want for our lives and you may not
even know and that's okay like you may
know where you want to go next but you
may not ultimately know the Final
Destination it's awesome
you know I think if you know the Final
Destination you're thinking small apart
from having a mission you know the
mission the purpose why do you do what
you do I want to solve the world's
biggest problem people don't believe in
themselves enough that's what I'm
chasing down every day
do I know where I'm going to be in in a
year nope am I still making videos
probably but who knows like question
everything I wanna I want people to
believe in themselves more what's the
best way to do that right now it's
through YouTube
but I think a lot of times people have
too certain of a plan and then they end
up
plain small because there's nothing
wrong with having goals and planes but
sometimes you need to jump off that if
you have a 10-year goal quite often you
need to jump off that goal two years in
because something better has come along
that actually better serves who you are
right now because the goal you set was
for who you used to be
you know have you felt that and so I'm
here at genius Network and this group of
super successful entrepreneurs that
meets once a month in masterminds and
talk about their business and pay a lot
of money to be a part of something like
this and every time I'm around people
who are who are having a high degree of
success
I always try to have them pick me apart
so when we when we do there's an
exercise called hot seats where you go
around the table and you basically share
what your biggest
what you think your biggest problem is
and whenever it gets to my turn I just
want people to ask me questions
because
your biggest problem is you don't know
what your biggest problem is
right your biggest problem is you don't
know what your biggest problem is if you
knew what your biggest problem was you
can go and solve it
for for entrepreneurs for ambitious
people for you've got goals it's like
you don't know what the real problem is
the problem you think you have is a
problem you know the problem you think
you have yes very much is a problem but
there's a deeper problem underneath it
that you're missing
that I'm missing so this is where
question everything becomes important my
default has become instead of pretending
like I know everything and I know all my
problems that I don't know anything and
ask me questions and in the process of
asking me questions and learning about
me maybe you come up with some insight
that I've never seen before
everybody has their own way of
processing
given advice you know so I'm around
people here everybody here has a seven
or eight figure or nine figure business
and people who have sold their
businesses
for nine figures crazy
awesome
and so they have their own way of
processing things and asking questions
and breaking somebody down
so instead of me coming in with
the question and having them try to fit
into my box I'd rather fit into theirs
because in trying to understand how they
process things
it'll probably make me stretch and grow
and learn
and I'm probably going to get a better
result because they're going to see
something that I don't see
and so
in the process of questioning everything
when people can break you down and
you're open to it right because we're we
hold on to our identity like no no
that's not going to work for me you know
even boom you gotta be I am allergic to
bees
maybe I should question that I don't
feel like questioning that today though
do not want to get stung by a bee I once
got stung by a bee and uh only time in
my life I've been sung by a bee and it I
was on the floor and my my back just
swelled up from the bee sting
um
anyway maybe question everything except
bee stings how about that uh there's
been times when people have given me
advice and it made sense and it really
fit and sometimes when it didn't
and and even if it doesn't make sense
what I'll default in my head the saying
is this is either nothing like the
person didn't read me correctly or it's
the whole thing
think about if you're really opposed to
somebody's advice or feedback for you if
somebody gives you great advice like oh
wow that's really cool I should go and
do that cool they they met you where you
were at and you understand it
but there'll be other times when it it
doesn't feel right
and it could be that it just wasn't a
fit and they're giving you the wrong
advice or
you're so blind and this is what gets me
excited is maybe I'm so blind maybe I
believe my story so much that the thing
that you're talking about is actually
the whole thing like it's all I should
care about because figuring out how to
solve that because I'm so tied to my own
story that I'm not questioning enough
and coming back to the B Spot hopefully
it's gone I'm not questioning enough
and figuring that out becomes the the
whole unlock so a quick story on this I
did a life coaching session with
garyvee's lead coach Beth hendel and at
first I was shocked I didn't know I
didn't know garyvee had a life coach so
I was very excited to talk to her and
just like I've been explaining this
video I went through her process like
like how do you ask questions what do
you want to know about me I don't want
it to be if this is a coaching session
just treat me as a shoot me as a client
treat me as somebody who's going to
coach what do you need to know from my
story and how I act and I'm gonna I'm
gonna be as open as honest as possible
and what it led to was
a lot of the stuff she was saying
um was great but my single biggest
insight and takeaway was this and I'm
practicing this every single day now
the one takeaway that has honestly
changed my life
historically I've been the person who
believes in the plan
so what's my plan to get to the next
step like I want to go here what's my
plan what's my plan what's my plan so I
have the belief in the plan and I wake
up every day and I just do the plan
because I believe in the plan
I'll have some days where I don't
believe in a plan anymore like will this
plan help get me anywhere is this plan
still working like it's not working
anymore and that leads to some anxiety
for me because I believe in the plan and
when the plan doesn't work what happens
and so what I end up doing is making a
new plan
so I have a plan I believe in a plan
until I don't believe in it anymore
causes anxiety come up with a new plan
the following so when creating a new
plan then I have certainty in the plan
again and I'm fine and I'm rock and
rolling but there are some days there
are some days when I can't come up with
a new plan the plan I have I don't
believe in anymore and I'm racking my
brain to come up with a new plan and I
can't come up with a new plan
if I'm the kind of person who believes
in the plane and then I can't come up
with a new plan that's a really uh
stress-inducing anxiety-filled place to
be and it doesn't happen that often
but when it does and I can't come up
with a new plan especially in the moment
while what I would end up telling myself
is great things happen to me you know
what you know what happened great things
happen to you
and I would use it as a self-soothing
mechanism as a coping mechanism
because I didn't want to just stay
locked because locked in that stress and
and it would be downward spiral like if
I believe in the plan and the plan is
not working and I can't come up with a
new plan then I don't know what to do
with my life and that would create a
downward spiral I've never gone anywhere
close to depression or suicide but that
would lead to some dark that could lead
to some dark places and so the way that
I come out of it is just say great
things will happen to me great things
happen to me they already they always
happen to me great things happen to me
and I'll figure this out and that gives
me the Comfort to
move forward into the uncertainty and
then something will come that I will
solve it and what she said was garyvee's
life coach was
what you say to yourself
when you need that
self-soothing of great things happen to
you
needs to be your default state
so instead of believing in the plan as
your default State and only going to
great things happen to you when you are
at the lowest of your low
flip it to the point where great things
happen to you is the default
because that's where you're actually
your best self and I really felt that I
don't know how to do it
but even in questioning how do I do it
I just have to believe the great things
happen to me so a big part of my routine
now is is I don't know how many times
I'll I'll say that to myself feel that
great things happen to me I'm going to
put it as my new cell phone background
it's a it's a constant reminder even
making this video is another
reinforcement of it when people ask me
what my goals are there's been these
exercises we've been doing in genius
Network here and uh I just I just keep
reminding myself I don't know I don't
have a 10 year goal great things happen
to me
it's a constant reminder and I
I would I used to live it before this
awareness
I don't know like how many times would I
feel really down and low in
anxiety-filled that I couldn't come with
a new plan
maybe half of one percent of the time
like really small amounts and now I'm
probably living in great things happen
to me maybe
five percent of the time ten percent of
the time which is a huge jump from half
of one percent but it's still not my
default mode yet I'm still believing a
planned guy that's my ongoing challenge
to myself that's how I'm questioning
it's the willingness to question what
you're doing because what you're doing
right now has gotten you to where you're
at and if you're if you're happy with
where you're at cool but if you want
more you want to create more you want to
serve more you want to bring more you
want to help more you want more
you want to change and you have to
change
and the change starts with not just
questioning everything out there
question everything in here
questioning what you believe to be true
question who you think you are
questioning for sure what you think
you're capable of
because when you can get to the root of
that amazing things can happen
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to reprogram your mind check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there I'm in the mind is
like a computer program and the fact
that it's on a negative Loop is because
we programmed it on a negative load but
you know we could have been influenced
from her children and things like that
one of the things that the Mind loves is
loves repetition I mean he loves it